i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story i'm taylor armstrong one of
the og's from the real housewives of
beverly hills and a current cast member
on the real housewives ultimate girls
trip and i'm the woman yelling at cat
well you've seen the picture so what
exactly am i yelling about in order to
explain that i need to go back right
away i grew up in oklahoma with a single
mom my household had abuse when i was
quite young and thankfully my mother was
strong enough to get me out of that
situation when i was a toddler and then
i had a really great life for a child
who didn't have a father i had visited
la in orange county a lot growing up
because my parents moved there when i
was 17. so i spent a lot of time in la
but living in beverly hills is a little
bit different than orange county it's
quite glamorous and it was a real
eye-opener to how the other half lived i
met my ex-husband at the four seasons
hotel i was waiting for a friend he was
there with a large group waiting for a
table we talked a little bit we started
dating and my first impression of him
was that he was a little bit aloof but
he had a very charismatic personality i
had no idea what was in store for me i
ended up on real housewives because
adrian maloof and i go way back and she
had gone in for the casting and
mentioned me
and then they contacted me and i went in
and
things just took off you know they
picked the original six of us for a
reason we had great synergy it was the
perfect kickoff for beverly hills the
lifestyle in beverly hills is just over
the top it's just it's like glitz and
glamour everywhere you look but all that
glitters isn't gold i can tell you that
there's certainly some pressure that
comes with it because you are
in a situation where there is arguing
and things can get pretty tense we would
fight in the day or fight at a party on
the show and then i would go home and
there would be fighting in my home while
i was filming beverly hills i was in an
abusive marriage my husband was verbally
and physically abusing me for almost six
years my husband
many times told me that he was afraid he
was going to kill me someday when he
would get completely out of control
there were times when i thought that was
possible as well i was terrified word
would get back to my husband if i shared
my story with any of the ladies on
beverly hills or really my other friends
for that matter and it's a real
challenge for victims because you bring
your friends on a roller coaster ride
with you when i want them to still be
nice to him but yet they can see that he
doesn't treat me well but i don't want
that to get back to him so i'm asking
them basically to be nice to someone who
they know is not being nice to me and
that's hard for your friends and family
and people that love you it's a
challenge for all victims so camille was
another one of our cast members she was
married to kelsey grammer at the time
and she was going through a divorce
actually um there were a lot of divorces
on beverly hills but camille went
through a tough one we were at lisa's
tea party camille outed my abuse and i
was in shock i remember looking over at
our producer across the way and just
staring at him thinking something about
my life is going to change because this
is going to end up on television and i
have an abuser who is completely out of
control and i don't know if that means
that he's gonna kill me are we gonna get
a divorce is this gonna make him behave
is he finally gonna go to anger
management like what of all this myriad
of options is going to happen i was
terrified
i was walking into the malibu party in
fear
and i don't think anyone recognized how
dangerous my life was at the time i was
very upset
i really wanted to get my point across
that you don't understand what you've
done to me you've outed something that
can't be put back and the consequences
for me and my child could be dire if
something were to happen to me it would
have destroyed my daughter's life and
for them to not be conscious of that and
to be considerate of the fact that i was
living in fear and in danger
the last time
my former husband hit me um was on my
birthday and
he fractured my orbital floor and i have
a titanium implant holding up my right
eye and once i saw the radiographic
evidence of what he had done i was able
to come to terms with the fact that
this was going way too far i could have
lost my eye
you know things could have gone even
worse at that point and i remember
waking up in recovery after having my
surgery and
my mom and my best friend were sitting
in the room with me and then they
wheeled me down to see my daughter
and
looking at her
i thought this is it like i have to take
care of the other people in my life even
if i don't have
enough self-respect to get myself out of
the situation i have to do it for my
family and my friends
the first time i saw the meme it was in
2019 someone sent it to me
and then they started popping up
everywhere and i sent it to kyle and
she's like i don't get it i was like i
don't get it either and everybody's like
why are you yelling at that cat
i don't have any idea who the cat even
is
so first of all i wouldn't yell at an
animal to begin with but i certainly
wouldn't be yelling at this fluffy
little white cat soon it was everywhere
it was all over the internet there were
paintings sweaters board games wood
block prints it was insane people are so
creative and it just it still keeps
coming it's unbelievable a lot of people
have asked me if the meme upsets me
because it was such a traumatic moment
in my life and it doesn't my life back
then seems like someone else's life it's
so far in the past for me and i've come
so far since then that i find the meme
hysterical i'm incredibly happy and
so much stronger so much stronger than i
was then i work with
victims and survivors i work with a lot
of shelters um i do a lot of public
speaking my favorite place to speak is
colleges and universities because i feel
like it's the first time you're away
from your parents and you really have
the opportunity to make bad decisions so
i try to share my story and tell them
all the things i did wrong that ended me
up in an abusive relationship so that
they can make different choices and
stand up for themselves and know their
value i'm super excited for people to
watch the real housewives ultimate girls
trip on peacock it's berserk in the
berkshires stay tuned
[Music]